foreign
[Music]
of losing the elections because all
opinion polls show that they are going
to be decimated therefore there are
there they just are running scared of
the election and they're willing to even
violate the constitution
[Music]
every lawyer in Pakistan has said
that the moment you dissolve your
assemblies no government elections have
to be held within 90 days I mean this is
UN ambiguous
[Music]
thank you
so if the government says in October
well why not in December why not next
year the moment General Zia got out of
the 90 days when he came into power and
he said I will hold elections in 90 days
the moment he got away he lost for 11
years
oh my God
at the moment all we rely on our
remittances from overseas pakistanis we
can we we cannot attract their
investment
why can't we attract the investment
because they do not have confidence in
our judicial system and the rule of law
[Music]
the current civil and Military imbalance
has to change if you want to Pakistan to
get out of this mess you cannot wish
away the role of military in Pakistan
because it's entrenched for 70 years but
you need that balance
[Music]